We can also think of these inputs as one set, and these outputs as another set.
Our relation is a rule that describes the relationship between this set of
inputs and this set of outputs. In this case, the relationship is the vowels
found in each persons name. This relation though is actually very special, it's
actually a function. A function is unique because the inputs always give the
same outputs. For example, Bob will always give us a letter o. Functions may
have two different inputs like Tim and Jill that both produce the same output,
in this case Jill and Tim both give us i. This is okay. This would not be a
function because we can never have two different outputs, a and o, for one
input, in this case, Bob. For a function, each input must correspond with
exactly one output. So there can only be one arrow leading from any input to an
output.